>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> In 2008 you know of course
that Jeff Smith is best known
as writer and artist of Bone.
It's an award-winning adventure
about his three cartoon cousins lost
in a world of myth
and ancient mysteries.
In 2008 Smith was the subject of a
documentary called The Cartoonist:
Jeff Smith, Bone and the
Changing Face of Comics.
And besides Bone, Jeff has also
written some other books including
Shazam, The Monsters Society of
Evil and Little Mouse Gets Ready.
So everybody get ready to put your
hands together for Jeff Smith.
[Applause]
>> Jeff Smith: Hi everybody
for everyone coming out today
in this unbelievable heat.
Let's see.
Now how do I write on this?
Is there like a pen or --
[ Sound effects ]
>> [Inaudible background question]
>> No I'm sorry.
[Laughter]
>> Jeff Smith: This is
probably going to be pretty hard
for everybody to see,
but we'll do our best.
>> Thank you.
>> Jeff Smith: I'm going to
draw just a few quick pictures,
make a short presentation
and get right to questions,
because I like to talk
to kids anyway, so.
You know when I go to book
events like this, it's new.
It's a new experience for me
to be considered a book writer,
because when I started reading --
you know started drawing comics
and definitely when I started
reading them comics were --
they were not considered
really reading.
I think it might have even gone
the other way and people thought
that comics caused illiteracy.
And I'm not making that up.
I even as a kid, even when
I was 7 years old I knew
that comics was reading.
You read it just like a book.
You know you go left to right, top
to bottom, just like a regular book.
But there are certain kinds of
symbols and pieces of language
that are unique to comics.
Surprisingly we all know them
you know like sweat flying
out of the head means
you're nervous or worried.
A little cloud coming off the back
of your feet means you're running.
These kind of symbols,
they're unique to comics.
But they work together with
the words and the balloons
and the images are all part
of the storytelling together.
So I want to just start by talking
about what it was that made me want
to go into comics and
into cartooning,
just going to do something normal.
But I think when I was
looking at comics as a kid,
maybe I can pulled this closed.
I gotta figure out how
I'm going to do this.
I guess I'll say it
and then go draw it.
One of these that interested
me like Snoopy or Donald Duck
or Bugs Bunny is that you could see
where the characters were looking.
You could see their eyes or just
with the eyebrows or whatever
and you could tell what
they were thinking.
So I'll draw Fone Bone and
then maybe I'll come back
and talk about it.
[ Sound effects ]
>> Jeff Smith: Okay,
so this is Fone.
And he is -- if you're familiar
with the Bone characters,
which most of you are,
he's the friendly one.
He's the more curious cousin.
He's the one that we
probably most all want to be
like or think we are like.
But what's interesting, or I
don't know if it's interesting,
but what I want to try to convey
is you see his body position.
He's talking here to Ted the bug.
And he's leaning forward
and he's smiling
and his eyebrows are
kind of up in the air.
His one hand is back.
It's all very unthreatening.
He's interested in
what Ted has to say.
This is part of the
language of comics.
And also you probably
didn't notice that I do it,
but when I drew Ted the
bug, I actually kind
of traced a little line, an
invisible line from his eyes
so I could tell where
he was looking.
So now I'll draw a
different character.
[ Sound effects ]
>> Jeff Smith: You
can't enough Urrgh.
[Laughter] How did you
sign that by the way?
[Laughter] So here this is
Fone's cousin Phoney Bone
and he's a much -- well as you
can see he's a much crankier,
angrier character and again
I use his body position.
He's kind of hunched over.
You can see his fists
are all balled up.
He's got -- he's baring his teeth.
His eyebrows are frowning and
of course, there's all sorts
of like lightening
bolts and there a plumes
of clouds coming off his head.
And of course, the
famous word balloon
where we know what he's saying.
[ Sound effects ]
>> Jeff Smith: This is the
third bone cousin, Smiley Bone,
so called because he smiles.
And Smiley Bone, he's a
more whimsical character.
And I've portrayed this by
having him play an instrument.
His eyes are closed.
His dogs hang out of his mouth --
his tongue hangs out of
his mouth like a dog.
Sorry this is nervous
looking out here and seeing --
it makes me nervous seeing
all these people out here.
So that's the three bone
characters, the three main cousins
and then I would just like to try
to do a quick demonstration here
of how you -- how I
as a cartoonist write.
How do you write in cartoons?
And the basic -- the
smallest like element or piece
of writing in comics are unit.
Sorry. Let me just say that again.
The smallest unit of writing, in
comics, is any two given panels.
So if you draw one panel where
Smiley Bone is standing there --
[ Sound effects ]
>> Jeff Smith: When someone's
running it always helps
to put a little shadow underneath
them and a little could of dust.
So in this panel, let's
add one more thing.
The little could of dust.
Oh and let's add one more thing.
[ Sound effects ]
>> Jeff Smith: The banana peel.
Alright so, of course you probably
know what's going to happen
but it's crucial to like see it.
[ Sound effects ]
>> Jeff Smith: Alright there's
a couple important elements
that I need to add in.
The swoosh line of his foot.
Oh I need to put the banana peel.
[ Sound effects ]
>> Jeff Smith: And there we go.
And with these two panels
we now have an action.
The reader whether he's a nine year
old kid or a fifty year old man
like me, that -- you may
make the action happen;
its two totally separate
pieces of art.
And yet when you put the
two together it's that jump
from one panel to the next where
you can turn it into movement.
I think we need a third
panel though.
[ Sound effects ]
>> Jeff Smith: Alright
so you get the idea.
It's leaping -- this little space
between the panels
actually has a name.
It's called the gutter and it's
actually jumping over the gutter,
that actual magic or the actual
reading that really takes place
when you're doing a comic.
[Applause] That's it really.
That's it.
Thank you.
[Applause] So what we'd like to do
now, if there's any kids or anybody
who wants to ask a question or
anything we have some microphones.
If you could line up behind
the microphones we'll talk.
[ Sound effects ]
>> Jeff Smith: Alright
so let's start over here.
What's you name?
Is there a sound person?
[ Sound effects ]
>> Jeff Smith: Sound guy.
He's like, "What?"
Why don't we start over here?
>> Okay.
>> Jeff Smith: You got it now?
>> My name is Collette.
>> Jeff Smith: Hi Collette.
>> What gave you the idea of just
the whole setting like the --
like how was Fone Bone so
grumpy and like how did you make
up the whole dragon and all that?
>> Jeff Smith -- I, I --
okay how do I explain that.
[Laugher]
>> What gave you the idea?
>> Jeff Smith: When I was like
five I really wanted to make
up my own cartoon character.
Back then Peanuts were
in the newspaper.
Every Sunday night Walt
Disney used to be on TV.
He was still alive then.
And he would introduce
his character.
So I knew that Walt Disney made
up Mickey Mouse and Donald Duck.
I knew that Charles
Schultz made up Peanuts.
So I thought I want to make
up a cartoon character.
I just kept trying.
I made up all sorts of them.
I made up dogs and worms and
birds and super heroes and things.
But this little guy kind
looked kind of like a bone.
You now he's got this
round head and his big nose
and he looks like a dog bone.
He just kind of stuck with me and I
think the reason he stuck with me is
because of -- what I was talking
about a little bit here is
like I could see his
different emotions.
I actually thought it was
fun to solve the puzzle
of what would it look like if you
turned his head around in space
and like saw him from the back.
Or if he was angry or he was
tired, how would he look?
How would I draw it really?
So I drew those kind of
classic American big-nosed,
three-fingered characters
all my life.
And then when I was in college there
was a magazine called Heavy Metal,
which we all know now and it's
kind of a cheesecaky magazine,
but back when it first came
out, it was very different.
It was a bunch of European
cartoonists who did a fantasy,
like a science fiction
fantasy for grownups.
And it was really genius,
really well done.
And I thought, "You know
what, if you take Bugs Bunny
or Mickey Mouse characters
and put them in this
like heavy metal fantasy world or
put Bugs Bunny into a real book
like Moby Dick or [Inaudible]
don't worry.
[Laughter] I thought it would
be fun, so that's what I did.
By the way, I see you're holding
the Bone one volume edition there.
Are your arms getting tired?
>> Yeah.
>> Jeff Smith: Can I
ask how old you are?
>> I'm ten.
>> Jeff Smith: And you've
already read that whole thing?
>> No, but I actually
just got it today.
>> Jeff Smith: And
you're still holding it?
>> I've almost read
half of the Bone series.
I've actually -- I didn't
hear of them until last year
when my friend pointed
them out to me
and I got them from
my school library.
>> Jeff Smith: Well
that's wonderful.
Thank you.
Thank you Collette.
[Applause]
>> And do you think I can get
one of those pictures you drew?
>> Jeff Smith: Yeah, you can
talk to someone over here.
I'm going to stay out of that.
[Laughter] Yes?
>> Okay I like the way you draw
where you just start
like piecing it out.
And when you made up the Bones
picture did it sort of just
like flow with your pencil?
Do you think of these
pictures before you draw them
or do you just write
something down and just see it?
>> Jeff Smith: I think
I understand that.
Did you get -- can everybody hear
all the questions and everything.
Alright the question was when
she saw me drawing the characters
and it looked like I was moving
around in different
parts and drawing them.
I think you're asking do
I see it before I draw it.
Is that right?
>> Um huh.
>> Jeff Smith: It's actually
a really good question
and I try to do that.
I try like before I start
I kind of already know
where everything is going to be.
I kind of picture the
drawing and then just kind
of trace my imagination
as I'm seeing it.
I have certain little tricks,
which I'll try to show you one.
I'm trying to think of an example.
Let's say Fone Bone was
going to throw a baseball.
Well that would be
a hard thing to do.
So what I'll do is I'll
picture in my head, "Okay,
he's probably" -- is that right?
I don't know.
I don't play baseball.
[Laughter]
[ Sound effects ]
>> Jeff Smith: But this is the
trick I'm going to tell you
about because it's kind of unnatural
for a little cartoon character
because he doesn't like really
have bones, not real ones.
So what I would draw after I got
the position down of his head,
and got his determined throwing
face, now I'm going to draw his hand
and I'm going to put it where
it would be interesting.
[ Sound effects ]
>> Jeff Smith: Okay, so now
I'm not really going to worry
about how long his arm is anything.
I'm just going to connect
it up to his body.
[ Sound effects ]
>> Jeff Smith: Alright.
Okay, thank you.
[Applause]
>> What inspired you to make like
the evil character Briar sisters
with Grandma Ben, like
the good character?
>> Jeff Smith: There are twins --
twins happen a lot in storytelling.
Stories that go way back
all the way to roman times
and even earlier than that.
It's a very popular kind
of motif to tell stories
and it's all throughout Bone.
So you see you'll have
Fone Bone and Phoney Bone.
You have the good one
and the bad one.
So basically it's just
kind of like a running joke
so to speak throughout all Bone.
So you have not only Fone Bone and
Phoney Bone, you have Grandma Rose,
you have Rose and you have Briar.
So there's just -- a lot
of times there's two.
It's just kind of a
story kind of trick.
>> Okay.
>> Jeff Smith: Okay, thanks man.
Yes.
>> First I'd just like to say I'm
a really big fan of your work.
>> Jeff Smith: Thanks man.
>> So again I was researching
you on the internet one day
and I read somewhere that you
at one point challenged
fellow cartoonist Dave Simms
to a boxing match.
Would you mind telling
the story behind that?
[Laughter]
>> Jeff Smith: That's a great story.
Except it was the other way around.
He challenged me to a match.
>> Oh okay.
>> Jeff Smith: But he also -- he
didn't want to do any of the work.
He wanted me to like
set up the boxing ring.
It was silly.
We got in a fight.
We were mad at each other and
I don't know it was silly.
[Laughter] I don't want
to tell that story.
You can find out about it on the
internet if you really want to.
[Laughter] Alright, thanks man.
Go ahead.
>> What is the story
of the red dragon?
>> Jeff Smith: The
story of the red dragon.
Now how do I tell that
story to kids?
The story of the red dragon is in
stories you need to have a mentor,
a kind of guardian
angel type character.
Well in Star Wars that
was Obi Wan Kenobi.
Well in Bone it's the
Great Red Dragon.
He kind of watches over them.
The idea of the character
came from --
around the world dragons have
different meanings and in the east
like in China dragons
are very good characters.
They represent water and wind and
they are protective guardians.
They're good.
They're like good powers,
whereas in the west
in our culture dragons
are usually bad.
They're fire-breathing.
They always want to hoard
princesses and gold,
things they really have no use for.
They're bad.
So I thought maybe the very
first dragon would be a very good
benevolent dragon and then
that dragon who's Queen Mim
in the bone story, her son
would be the red dragon.
So he's sort of a western
dragon, breathes fire
and an eastern dragon who's a
guardian and he has a goatee,
sort of like Chinese dragons do.
And then all the other
dragons, the eastern
and western dragons
all descended from him.
So that was sort of
like his mythology.
Alright, thanks.
Yes sir.
>> So when you draw Bone do
you think about how more --
the swordplay and fighting
the creatures
and all the other guys
that's more of Grandma Ben
and Thorn's department, but it's
usually except for one part in --
>> Jeff Smith: Okay.
>> It's never the Bone brothers.
>> Jeff Smith: So let
me see if I understand.
You're saying that when
I'm writing am I --
do I compartmentalize
it or is one --
is the adventure part more
important than the funny part?
>> No. It's --
>> Jeff Smith: Go ahead.
>> They never really pick up a
sword and do a lot of fighting.
>> Jeff Smith: Right.
>> It's more Thorn style
and Grandma Ben's style.
>> Jeff Smith: Yeah, well
I think of the Bones,
they're cartoon characters.
And they're classic comedy slapstick
comedians like the Marx Brothers
or Mickey, Donald and Goofy.
And their job isn't really
to do the adventure stuff.
You know their job is to
get in trouble basically
and that's how it works out.
And sort of the Luke Skywalker
part of the story that fell
to Thorn and Grandma Ben to do.
So I did think that
they should be separate.
Okay sure.
Okay we're getting down.
We got about two more
minutes left so let's try
to ask a couple more
questions quick.
>> Well do you have any advice
to fellow storytellers how
to balance -- when to write
stories that balance like comedic,
really silly, really funny, really
fun stuff with mythology and epic?
>> Jeff Smith: Well I've always
liked comedies that forget
that they're comedies for awhile.
I think one of the movies
that really struck me was
American Werewolf in London,
which is a comedy but it's also one
of the most terrifying
films I've ever seen.
Ghostbusters did a really good job
of balancing humor and big scale
and you know end of the
world cataclysmic stuff.
So my best advice would find
examples of it, you know
and just read it and do your best to
reconstruct it and see how it works.
Watch it a couple of
times, whatever.
That's what I did.
Does that help at all?
>> Yeah thank you.
>> Jeff Smith: Alright.
>> Are you going to
create anymore books?
>> Jeff Smith: I am going
to create more books.
I'm probably not going to create
anymore Bone books I'm sorry to say.
We are doing a series
of -- well hey --
we're going to do a series of books
that are pros books that I'm going
to do the illustrations for.
But I really didn't
want them to be sequels
and my one rule was I didn't want
the three Bone cousins to be in it
because I don't really like
-- I don't like sequels.
I really think once the story is
over it should be done and kind
of -- it's up to you to imagine
what happens to the characters
and where they go after that.
Alright last question.
>> From all the books you've
written so far, how --
which one is your favorite
Bone cousin to write about?
Like can you describe it?
>> Jeff Smith: You know they're
all my favorite sometimes.
Phoney Bone is so much fun 'cause
he always says such nasty things
that I could never
really say in real life
and it's really fun
to do that sometimes.
But in all honesty it
has to be Fone Bone.
He's probably the one I
most closely identify with
and he's my guy, alright.
Well I will thank you
everyone for coming.
Time's up.
Thank you.
[Applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at www.loc.com.